hello my name is Treecko
I play for hunger in Jeju
III before a similarly similarly played
RT like a legal legend became oh but I I
want to try on newer and I tried season
one last lost the last season and I
totally enjoy celebrating for a season 2
season 3 I only solo que siento all I am
my faceplate oh so good so I think I'm
good I can be good pro-gamer so I wanted
to try ok my parents don't like of game
but after well I I join cheesy then my
parents told me
see trick in the lineup right now and
there's thinking all right new guy huh
you're not getting the reksai and you're
going to have to play against an
invisible jungler I did test
well test is over so 30 days after all
she's a coach they come gaming off and
ice cream and play play and I cheated my
people it he made my drive or max happer
I miss them after all
I end up contractor in shitty or I have
any offers but III don't want to solve
because I installed one year so jittery
scooty yeah I I saw all every team is
solo solo queue length g2 is high
lengths of echo GT
and honestly if you are starting younger
and you need to learn something about
jungle efficiency you need to follow
what trick does because somehow the
always smoothly transitions to the game
he almost never falls behind I feel like
good because before he I'm just a
cellphone now I'm Sutter and BPA no this
splitter I have a most empathy if I have
many a baby I get very confident so I
don't get pressure because in MSA I just
meant tire is boom so I can't think
about all someone spray or I think total
after me say I prayed way wash so yeah
it is so major opera sometimes of meat
even table I can't I can't shock or for
normally Matisse measure for that I can
take it in the back end copy ties is
expect completes his teleports in Megan
or that one is running for his life
track she's running can't touch the ice
barrel it's a double kill for trick
so I I just want to win worthy so well I
think you Iike
so we first place oh yeah I feel like
right I wanted I wanted go find her
I might my oh yeah right my core core
core is finer if if lucky I just want to
hit work good yeah